[Music]
methodology is use RNA seek data from
patients who were treated with the
chemotherapeutic drug um and use it to
train a random Forest classifier so the
classifier would just look at basically
pre and post uh treatment with the
chemotherapeutic drug the data set that
I use actually had samples from patients
before they were treated and samples
afterwards so it basically would just
look basically just classify the sample
as pre and post and then scanning the
available literature I would look for a
list of genes which have been implicated
in neuro degeneration otherwise and then
look at the future importance of those
genes in my model to see whether the
model basically used them to predict
whether the person had um been treated
with the chemotherapeutic agent or
not